it is time we recap the second night of
the Democratic debates the thrills the
chills and the spills I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show Wow so that
was a mess I mean that that's that's
really the big takeaway from the second
debate the first night seemed to have at
least something like an order last
night's debate was just a giant mess now
that doesn't mean we didn't learn some
useful things about each of the
candidates we're gonna go through all of
that in turn but what we learned about
the Democratic Party overall is that a
lot of people want to be President a lot
of people are gonna yell about it and
all those people are radically to the
left in this is a party that has moved
so far to the left it is nearly
unrecognizable when compared to even
with Barack Obama's 2008 platform
there's a party that has moved
dramatically to the left so far to the
left that Joe Biden is now seen as
anachronistic so far to the left that
anybody who proclaims that for example
it ought to remain illegal to cross the
border illegally those people are now in
the minority of the Democratic Party
this party has moved so far to the left
that the entire Democratic party last
night every single candidate on stage
suggested that American taxpayers should
foot the bill for the health care of
illegal immigrants so combine those two
factors basically open borders and
health care for everybody and what that
means is that we are getting get to pay
everybody's health care who wants to get
in and can cross that border illegally I
mean this is radical radical stuff but
that's not what these debates are are
really about in broad scope that's what
they're about because in the end that
will have an impact on how Americans
tend to think about these debates about
the parties about 2020 going forward it
half of half of the date last night will
be used in attack ads by President Trump
against any Democrat so if you thought
that night one was sort of an anomaly if
you thought that night one where
Democrats basically out pledged one
another to give free money to people was
is sort of an outlier that is not true
the heart and soul of the Democratic
Party is to the far left and they are
looking I guess for those extra three
votes in Los Angeles and New York and
they think somehow this is going to help
them win an election where they really
need Ohio Wisconsin in Pennsylvania I
didn't hear anything last night that
focused on folks you know
iö Pennsylvania Wisconsin any of those
areas this was all focused on the
progressive base in places like Iowa in
places like New Hampshire and so that
that's really what it was that's not
gonna bode well for the Democratic Party
over time they they simply think that
Donald Trump is so wildly unpopular that
they can say whatever crazy thing they
want to say and that won't become the
issue I am far more skeptical than that
I think that the 2020 election is going
to be about whom are we talking about
are we talking about Trump is from still
the center of attention or is it
whatever kooky Democrat is out there
proclaiming to the skies that they are
going to rewrite the American compact
and tear down the American Constitution
because all Democrats had to do was not
be crazy that's all they had to do they
did not show it last night okay so let's
jump into the bait the big loser of the
night was Bernie Sanders I know this is
controversial a lot of folks think that
Bernie Sanders is not the big loser and
the big loser was Joe Biden we'll get to
Biden don't worry but to me the big
loser was Bernie Sanders why well
because in the first night of the
Democratic debates Elizabeth Warren
failed to shine she wasn't terrible just
wasn't anything special she sort of
faded second half of the debate she was
pretty boring she didn't break out from
the pack and that pack I mean those are
those are ankle biters I mean those that
the the rest of that pack are
Lilliputians and Warren didn't break out
so that meant that Bernie had a chance
to seize back control of the progressive
narrative the problem is that because
Bernie has never thought through any of
his ideas he ended up just yelling at
the clouds I mean it was like Homer
Simpson's father is running around
Springfield yelling at things and that's
what Bernie Sanders was last night it
didn't work it came up particularly
poorly he didn't have any shining
moments hit all of his all of his lines
are basically hackneyed and old I think
you're watching the beginning of the end
of Bernie Sanders in real time so here's
Bernie Sanders being forced by Savannah
Guthrie last night answer a very simple
question are you gonna raise taxes on
the middle class didn't go great for him
will you raise taxes for the middle
class in a Sanders administration people
who have health care on the Medicare for
all will have no premiums no deductibles
no
copayments no out of expand out of
pocket expenses yes they will pay more
in taxes but less in healthcare so that
is not a great answer that is an answer
that is going to hurt him right don't
worry you're gonna pay less in taxes
you're gonna pay less in healthcare but
you're gonna pay way more in taxes
that's not an answer that is going to
help Bernie Sanders you know points for
honesty but this hasn't worked since
Walter Mondale D okay we're going to
raise your taxes dramatically pitch and
got worse for Bernie Sanders
the worst moment for Bernie Sanders is
when who specifically asked how he would
make Medicare for all work now I will
point something out about Sanders
there's no question the debate
moderators last night we're out to get
him there's no question that the debate
moderators last night asked the toughest
questions to Biden and Sanders and
fittingly I mean they are the two
frontrunners in the race but the tenor
of the questions to Biden and Sanders
was significantly harsher than the tenor
of the questions to Peabody dredge or
Kamala Harris neither of whom was really
asked about their record in any serious
way Biden and Sanders however were and
Sanders had no good answers which is
amazing because he's been running on the
same platform since 1932 when he was
still rallying with the Socialists at
City University of New York we'll get to
Bernie Sanders his worst moment in just
one second first I got to tell you
safety is deeply important to me
there's a reason for that people are
constantly threatening me and my family
well this means that I need a property
that is safe and that means that I rely
on ring rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer you might already
know about their smart video doorbells
and cameras that protect millions of
people ever we've got those ring also
helps you stay connected to your home
anywhere in the world so if there's a
package delivery surprise visitor you'll
get an alert and be able to see hear and
speak to them all from your phone that's
thanks to the HD video and two-way audio
features on ring devices as I say ring
is fantastic and it's worked for me
before I mean people have have rung the
doorbell and I don't know who they are
and I'm able to speak to them and make
clear that there is somebody at home and
that they should not go inside very
often a burglars do well well written
they'll ring the doorbell and then if
they don't get an answer then they rob
the house ring prevents that because you
bring the doorbell rings directly
through to your phone they can't tell
whether you're at home or whether you're
away
it really is terrific as a listener you
have a special offer on a ring starter
kit available right now
the video doorbell and motion-activated
floodlight cam the starter kit has
everything you need to start building
that ring of security around your home
just go to ring.com slash Bend that is
ring comm slash man I think it's vital I
think you'll find it vital to ring calm
/ Ben go check it out right now ring
calm / man ok so the worst moment of the
night for Bernie Sanders who's been
fading was was his answer on Medicare so
he was specifically asked about you have
this medicare-for-all plan and it's been
tried it a few state levels been tried
in Vermont they tried it they talked
about in California and they decided it
was Impractical so how is it that all of
these leftist states have tried Medicare
for all and it's been a giant fail but
your Medicare for all will work how are
you gonna make that happen
he's got nothing it's not succeeded in
other states of strength I will tell you
how we'll do it we'll do it the way real
change has always taken place whether it
was the labor movement the civil rights
movement or the women's movement we will
have Medicare for all when tens of
millions of people are prepared to stand
up and tell the insurance companies and
the drug companies that their day is
gone that health care is a human right
not something to make huge profits so
how are you gonna make that happen
he says well I'm gonna say that it's
going to happen yeah well but how is it
so here's how you want to know how I'll
make it happen
by saying so no but how is it gonna
happen say well I'm going to yell and
everybody else is going to yell and if
we all yell together I'll yell it will
be so loud that the walls of Jericho
will fall and everything I'm what'd he
say no the yelling is the key look what
what don't you understand I don't what
I'm saying - yelling is the key dude no
Bernie Sanders didn't win any points
last night like as in as in no points
last night so that's a problem for
Bernie because he's been losing momentum
to Elizabeth Warren she was lackluster
in night one and then he was even worse
in night two so this is a big bad night
for Bernie Sanders does that mean he
starts to crumble immediately no but
he's gonna continue that slow decline
into obsolescence that frankly he is so
richly deserved for years and I assume
that Elizabeth Warren will pick up some
of those votes and maybe Camille Harris
who will get to in just a second the
other person who had a bad night
Joe Biden so Joe Biden looked old he
felt old he did not seem on top of his
game now so far he has seemed impervious
so far nobody has really taken note of
any of his foibles he was attacked just
last week by Cory Booker on his comments
on on desegregation and and forced
busing his comments on segregationist
Senators his coming so in crime he was
attacked by Cory Booker over this it
didn't help Cory Booker at all but then
again Cory Booker wasn't facing him on a
stage
kamo harris was facing him on a stage
and the biggest moment of the night last
night bar none
for both harris and biden was this
exchange where Kamala Harris went after
Joe Biden on the issue of race it's a
long exchange we're gonna break it up
I'm gonna explain what's going on now
let me start with this come on her
sister deeply dishonest human being okay
what she's doing to Joe Biden here is
really dishonest so she is suggesting
that Joe Biden is a racist well saying
well I'm not really saying a racist but
you're kind of a racist what is the
basis for her claim that Joe Biden is a
racist her basis for that claim is that
Joe Biden back in the 1970s and 1980s
opposed forced busing a forced busing
was deeply unpopular policy at the time
it remains deeply unpopular today but
you're not allowed to say that because
anything that was well motivated but bad
policy on the issue of race is now
considered to be good policy that's how
this works so forced busing resulted in
more de facto segregation in American
life it resulted in white flight
it resulted in the devastation of tax
bases in more integrated cities as white
people fled it resulted in people taking
their money and their time out of the
public schools and putting it instead
into charter schools and private schools
forced busing was a very bad idea
there's a difference by the way between
getting rid of de jure like by law
segregation which of course is not only
moral but also good policy right getting
rid of the government discriminating
between the races and then trying to get
rid of de facto segregation meaning
people who are voluntarily separate in
their lives by forcing people to cross
lines by basically taking a bus and
putting it in a in a city and saying
we're gonna drive you out to the suburb
45 minutes so that we can achieve some
sort of unspecified racial balance in
schools this resulted in a lot of black
schools being shut down so that the
counties and the
dates could achieve racial balance by
forcing those black kids to be bused to
white schools it resulted in a lot of
white kids being pulled out of public
schools by their parents who didn't want
them bused to largely black schools not
because they were racist but because as
everyone knew this is the basis for
desegregation those black schools were
underfunded and poorly managed and
didn't have the resources or in an in
many case that the parental influences
that were necessary to build a great
public school in those areas you know
all of this resulted in some very bad
things but the idea is that if Joe Biden
opposed it must have been because he was
a racist not for any of the other
reasons it must have been because he was
a racist so Kamala Harris knows better
than this
she doesn't care she's a very very
cynical politician and so here she is
going after Joe Biden and essentially
claiming the same thing cory booker
claimed which is that even if she's not
gonna openly claimed that Biden's a
racist Biden's kind of racist now I will
note strategically this is very smart
not only is she impervious to any
counter attack from Biden on this
because she's a black woman but also she
is in a position to now run as his VP
should he win the nomination because she
can grant him absolution he he can then
select her and she can say you know what
I never said that Joe Biden was a racist
but she didn't read she sort of strongly
strongly implied it but this puts her in
a position to be his VP and then he can
say really if I'm such a racist then why
is this woman the standing next to me no
he tried that with Obama last night it
didn't work great here's the exchange
the key here is that Kamala Harris is
aggressive and Joe Biden looks tentative
at least at the beginning then he starts
to fight back and then he stops himself
that's the nature of the exchange the
other reason this is bad for Biden is
the optics so the optics are Joe Biden
is an old doddering guy and nobody
really knows why he is why he is running
other than he feels like he is owed this
Kamala Harris is very aggressive and if
you are a Democrat right now what you
want is somebody who is aggressively
going to prosecute Trump right that is
your case your case for Kamala Harris is
that Kamala Harris is very aggressive in
this exchange and that's good for her
because if she's willing to take on
Biden she's willing to take on Trump the
same dynamic applied by the way in 2016
Donald Trump's pure aggression on the
debate stage as opposed to all of the
other candidates made him the nominee
because people wanted to see him
take on Hillary Clinton and throw
everything including the kitchen sink in
her Kamala Harris exuded that last night
she was clearly the most prepared she
was clearly the the most well-spoken
candidate on the stage made with the
exception of people who to judge and she
had herself a really good night what
that meant in this exchange we're about
to play for you is that Joe Biden had a
really bad night I'll get to that in
just one second speaking of bad nights
if you slept poorly last night there's
no excuse for that you need a helix
sleep mattress you've heard me talk
about helix sleep before you know that
when I actually go out and I get an
advertiser's product as a gift for my
sister you know that it's a good product
okay helix sleep is that product my
sister's wedding I got her a helix sleep
mattress she asked for it because she'd
heard me talk about she says is it
really that good I said absolutely it's
that good why is it that good well it's
personalized to you helix sleep has a
quiz that takes two minutes to complete
it matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you no matter how you sleep on your side
your back hot sleeper whatever it is
helix can make what your body needs just
go to helix sleep calm slash men take
their two minutes sleep quiz they will
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you the best sleep of your
life for couples helix can even split
that mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side they've got a
ten year warranty you get to try it out
for a hundred nights risk-free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you certainly will helix is
offering up to one hundred and
twenty-five bucks off all mattress
orders for our listeners right now
you're really gonna love it I mean I've
got a helix sleep mattress and there's a
great deal get up to 125 bucks off at
helix sleep comm slash bed nets helix
sleep comm slash been from to one
hundred and twenty five dollars off your
mattress order helix sleep comm slash
man ok so here was the key exchange of
the entire evening here is Kamala Harris
the senator from California who's riding
at five or six percent in the polls just
high enough to start a base for momentum
go after Joe Biden consensus from the
night Kamala Harris big winner Joe Biden
not will see whether it has any impact
on polls right if she if he would stands
this and there's no damage in the polls
he's probably the nominee if however
there is any damage that measures here
if Kamala Harris gets a bump and Joe
Biden gets a bit of a decline this may
be the beginning of the end of Joe
Biden's candidacy here as Kamala Harris
going after Biden will break it up and
explain what's going on I do not believe
you are a racist
and I agree with you when you commit
yourself to the importance of finding
common ground but I also believe and it
is personal and I was actually very it
was hurtful to hear you talk about the
reputations of two United States
senators who built their reputations and
career on the segregation of race in
this country and it was not so she's
already mischaracterizing his comments
okay so his comments were that there
were these segregationists and they were
the worst people I knew and I had to
make deals with them that was the
entirety of the comments she's
immediately going to the cory booker
place which is you were praising
segregationist has nice guys and
wonderful people because you're a bad
person
now come Larissa's in the senate she
knows this is nonsense that's why it's
so cynical what she's doing here she I
mean this is a woman with no boundaries
my goodness there's a politician with no
boundaries now in a normal decent world
everybody would see through the game
that she is playing here but we don't
live in that world we live in a world
where if you invoke the very term racism
you have now put Joe Biden on the
defensive here's Harris and it was not
only that but you also worked with them
to oppose busing and you know there was
a little girl in California who was part
of the second class to integrate her
public schools and she was bused to
school every day and that little girl
was me so I will tell you that on this
subject
it cannot be an intellectual debate
among Democrats we have to take it
seriously we have to act swiftly as
Attorney General of California I was
very proud to put in place a requirement
that all my special agents would wear
body cameras and keep those cameras on
posit there we'll get some battens
response in just a second so what she's
doing there is she saying that just by
opposing force busing this makes you I'm
not saying you're a racist but it kind
of a racist is a bunch of crap okay
there's a big difference between forced
busing and desegregation okay there's a
forcible integration and desegregation
are not the same thing
forced busing was a government-sponsored
policy in non Jim Crow States by the way
in Boston right in Los Angeles in which
the government was forcing children
12-year olds to get on buses and go to
schools and places they didn't know far
from their homes both black kids and
white kids in an attempt to establish
some sort of statistical racial
integration it led to the very
predictable consequence of parents
pulling their kids out of those schools
in general moving them to private
schools or charter schools devastating
tax bases in precisely the cities that
needed the tax base to state the most
and led people to taya to to move from
those areas further and further into
suburbia leading to even more de facto
not - hurray - hurray means by law de
facto segregation forced busing was an
enormous policy failure
it was started with the best of
intentions the government didn't have
that authority and not only didn't the
government have that authority the
government was reaching into the private
lives of its citizens and forcing them
to do something this is a big problem
forced busing was bad policy an opposing
forced busing did not make you a racist
in many cases opposing forced busing was
about ensuring that people continue to
live together in the same community and
that schools were organized by community
as opposed to forcing people to get up
in the morning take a 45 minute drive
via bus to some other school they didn't
know in a community they didn't know as
I say black schools many of them were
forcibly shut down by the state because
they had to redistribute the black
students in such a way as to meet the
legal requirements set by the Supreme
Court Milliken was a case from 1980s all
of this was was bad policy all this was
bad policy but according to Kamala
Harris if you opposed the policy the
only reason you could have possibly done
that is because you're a racist and not
only that you would have you would have
stopped little Kamala Harris from going
to a better school if that had been the
case well no what if we
been in favor of for example school
vouchers which would have allowed you to
pick the school you wanted to go to as
opposed to the government forcing you to
go to a school that maybe you wanted to
go to it maybe you didn't want to go to
there are lots of alternative policies
that have been proposed by people who
opposed forced busing that would be more
effective in improving our public school
system but according to Kamala Harris
you would have stopped her from
succeeding as a human being if you had
stopped forced busing that's Joe Biden's
fault here's Joe Biden's response
[Applause]
this characterized my position across
the board I did not praise racist that
is not true
number one number two if we want to have
this campaign litigated on who supports
civil rights and whether I did or not
I'm happy to do that I was a public
defender I didn't become a prosecutor I
came out I left a good law firm to
become a public defender when in fact
when in fact when in fact my city was in
flames because of the assassination of
dr. King
number one no shaman there for a second
so Biden goes with the convenience
attack which is that she's a narc right
so already Biden is sounds tired right
she sounds emotional and enliven Biden
goes after her and he says I was a
public defender you were a narc lady
yeah that not not that not the strongest
to come back
not the strongest come back he does get
stronger as this combat goes on number
one not number two as the US excuse me
as the vice president on States I work
with a man who in fact we work very hard
to see to it we dealt with these issues
in a major major way the fact is that in
terms of bussing the busing I never you
would have been able to go to school the
same exact way because it was a local
decision made by your City Council
that's fine that's one of things argued
for that we should not be we should be
breaking down these lines but so the
bottom line here is look everything I've
done in my career I ran because of civil
rights I continued to think we have to
make fundamental changes in civil rights
and those civil rights by the way
include not just only African Americans
but the LGBT community
[Applause]
Kamala Harris's
answer on this in just one second so
Biden's final answer there is the right
one which is I've worked on civil rights
all my life for you to characterize me
as a racist is a vicious move you don't
have evidence of that by the way I
should note that forced busing was not
just unpopular with white Americans in
the 1970s it was unpopular with many
black Americans there's a 1972 Gallup
poll cited by slate okay not a
right-wing site showed that 77% of
whites were against busing in 1972 the
same poll showed that 47% of blacks were
against it as well in an article at
Slate all about this
particular times a very long and
thorough article by a guy named Tanner
Colby all about this specific issue he
talks about the effect of this he said
that it costs cities enormous amounts of
money it did not actually end with the
with the goals that it purported to
achieve it was deeply unpopular all the
way through says many black Americans
did believe in the school bus and the
access had provided busing might have
been a viable tool for those families
had had been smartly and surgically
applied it wasn't it was presented in a
sweeping fashion that did I had many
blacks the agency that they sought there
were huge problems in the policy just
because it was well motivated does not
mean that it was racist to oppose the
policy in a second we'll get to Kamala
Harris his response to Biden which again
she's gonna get deeply dishonest with
Biden you'll see we'll get that in just
one second first losing your hair sucks
okay I have male pattern baldness that
runs in my family and that's one of the
reasons why I am worried about losing my
hair two out of three dudes are going to
experience hair loss by the time they're
35 this is why you need keeps it's the
easiest most affordable way to keep the
hair that you have these fda-approved
products used to cost a lot but now
thanks to keeps their finally
inexpensive and easy to obtain for five
minutes now starting at just ten bucks
per month you're never gonna have to
worry about hair loss again getting
started is incredibly easy it takes less
than five minutes just answer a few
simple questions you can snap some
photos to complete your online doctor
consultation a licensed physician will
then review your information online and
recommend the right treatment for you
then it shipped direct your door every
three months keeps offers generic
versions and the only to FDA approved
hair loss products that are out there
you may have tried them before but
you're never going to have tried them
for this price only ten bucks to 35
bucks a month plus now you can get your
first month for free that's a hell of a
deal forgetting to keep your hair it's
something that I am worried about that's
why keeps is fantastic if you suffer
from hair loss the last thing you need
is to wait to see a doctor with keeps
there's finally a way to get the help
you need when you need it and you need
it right now because once the hair is
gone it probably ain't coming back these
FDA hair loss approved products stop the
hair loss okay but if you lose all your
hair you're bald and do anything about
that so you need to act right now for a
limited time receive your first month of
treatment for free go to keeps calm /
Ben again that's keeps calm / Ben for a
limited time get that first month of
treatment for free ke e PS calm
ke EPS calm go check them out right now
keeps calm @ / Ben first month for free
ok so Joe Biden responds to
and Kamala Harris responds again to Joe
Biden and doubles down again attacking
Joe Biden do you agree today
do you agree today that you were wrong
to oppose bussing in America though do
you agree I did not oppose busing in
America what I opposed is busing ordered
by the Department of Education that's
what I opposed was not a failure of
states to engineering
public schools in America I was part of
the second class to integrate Berkeley
California Public Schools almost two
decades after brown v board of education
because your City Council made that
decision himself in trouble right so so
Kamala Harris is demagoguing this issue
for sure but she is saying that the
federal government had to step in
because localities wouldn't do it
Biden is saying well wait a second I
didn't say that localities can't do it I
said that the Department of Education
should not step in from the top and
mandate this federally she's saying well
you know they're gonna be local
governments that didn't do it so if you
like forced busing then forced busing
should be federal policy so Biden is
trying to split the baby in much the
same way in much in much of the same way
that Mitt Romney tried to split the baby
when it came to questions about Romney
care people said okay well you pushed
Romney care back in Massachusetts why
not push it nationally and he said well
that's a states rights thing and people
were like well but you said it's good
policy so why not do it federally well
the same thing is happening to Joe Biden
in this particular debate he doesn't
have a good answer for it
his answer should be forced busing is a
well-intentioned policy that did not
have productive results you're not
allowed to say honest things though in
the democratic debate and how come Oh
Harris knows this she knows that Joe
Biden can't be on tape saying to Kamala
Harris that forced busing was a bad idea
that's why it's such a demagogic attack
because you can have an actual honest
discussion over forced busing but that
ain't what's happening on stage what's
happening on stage right here is Kamala
Harris starting off by saying that I'm
not saying you're a racist Joe but you
opposed forced busing and then if Biden
says right because forced busing was was
a bad idea she was well you only think
that cuz you're you're not a racist but
you're a racist but she's trapped him
here he has no place to go and finally
he gets frustrated he starts lashing out
and this is the best that Biden is and
then he
himself which is just ridiculous that's
why we need to pass the ER a because
there are moments in history where
states fail to preserve the civil rights
of our fg42 year all right from the very
beginning when I was thirty seconds but
I want to bring another supporter bring
a RA from the very beginning
I'm the guy that extended the Voting
Rights Act for 25 years we got to the
place where we got 98 of the 98 votes in
the United States Senate doing it I've
also argued very strongly that we in
fact deal with the notion of denying
people access to the ballot box I agree
that everybody once they in fact this my
times up anyway my time is up that's the
worst move he makes in this entire
exchange worst move he makes he's
finally gaining steam he finally has a
chance to answer and he goes to where he
should go which is the entire history of
my career is fighting for civil rights
and he lists off all of his supposed
accomplishments in this area and then he
says well I have to stop myself time is
up that's her key line right that's her
big win right there because first of all
it's an old guy saying that his time is
up
second of all it looks as though he is
looking to get out of the conflict by by
going to the timekeeper basically it was
a very bad moment for Joe Biden it
wasn't the only bad moment for Joe Biden
Joe Biden raised his hand when it came
to whether health care should cover
illegal immigrants for example everybody
in it every single Democrat on stage
raised their hand when asked if health
care government provided health care
should cover illegal immigrants which is
an amazing statement I'm old enough to
remember when Joe Wilson representative
Joe Wilson who I blues from South
Carolina was taken to task for going to
the State of the Union address with with
Barack Obama and shouting it Obama Obama
you lie when Obama said that his plan
would not cover illegal immigrants now
every Democrat is saying of course it
will cover illegal immigrants of course
that's where we're going so here is Joe
Biden raising his hand hands question
and hold them up for a moment so people
can see we as you're handed covered if
your government plan would provide
coverage for undocumented immigrants
every Democrat with every single
Democrat it's an amazing thing including
Joe Biden who did this sort of weird
thing repeatedly in the show of hands
situations when it looked like he
couldn't make up his mind again
underscoring the idea that maybe he's
out of touch maybe he's too old maybe
he's past his prime he would do this
routine where he sort of raised one
finger and kind of put it down and then
raised another finger it's it's it's a
very weird moment you can see him doing
it right here if you're watching the
show he everybody else kind of either
goes up with the hand or doesn't go up
with the hand he does kind of this weird
vacillating move doesn't look good for
him meanwhile and and there were a
couple other hits against Biden that
scored also right Eric's wall Wow who
really is just the worst horse Eric
Schwaab well who's irrelevant no one
cares about him he's basically there
just to just to effectively torpedo
people here was Eric's whoa whoa
torpedoing Biden and Biden's got nothing
I was six years old when a presidential
candidate came to the California
Democratic convention and said it's time
to pass the torch to a new generation of
Americans that candidate was
then-senator Joe Biden Joe Biden was
right when he said it was time to pass
the torch to a new generation of
Americans 32 years ago
I'm still hold on that torch okay that's
the best you can do you weren't prepared
for the year-old attack it's not exactly
I I will not comment to my opponents
youth in an experience it's not exactly
a Ronald Reagan line from 1984 that is
that is some weak tea there from Joe
Biden and it was weak tea all the way
through it now it's possible that it
doesn't affect him it's possible that
he's somewhat invulnerable then nothing
happens that in the end people look at
him they go okay we already know Joe
Biden we're not learning anything new we
know he's old we know he's vacillating
we know he's not too strong but he's the
guy who can beat Donald Trump maybe
that's what happens here or maybe he
looks like he was put back on his heels
by a freshman senator from California
maybe that's what it looks like because
that's what it looked like last night
which means the big winner was comel
Harris well get to common law Harris is
showing and why she is a particularly
frightening candidate I mean she's she's
a frightening candidate because she
openly espouses her own love of tyranny
it's pretty astonishing we'll get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about that credit card debt so for
decades credit cards have been telling
us to buy it now and pay for it later
with interest despite your best
intentions that interest can certainly
get out of control quickly with Lending
Club you can consolidate your debt or
pay off credit cards with one fixed
monthly payment since 2007 Lending Club
has helped millions of people regain
control of their finances with
affordable fixed-rate personal loans no
trips to a bank no high interest credit
cards just go to Lending Club com tell
them about yourself how much you want to
borrow pick the terms that are right for
you if you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform over
thirty five billion dollars in loans
issued so why in the world are you just
racking up that credit card debt letting
those interest charges rack up you're
getting behind the 8-ball you're never
gonna get out you need to go to my
friends over at Lending Club and check
them out go to Lending Club comm slash
Bend
check you're eight minutes bar up to 40
grand that's Lending Club comm slash
been Lending Club comm slash ban all
loans made my web bank member FDIC Equal
Housing lender go check them out right
now Lending Club comm slash Ben check
you're eight minutes borrow up to forty
grand make sure that you're not getting
behind the eight-ball with that credit
card debt be a responsible adult Lending
Club comm slash Ben and go check them
out right now okay
in just a second we're gonna get to the
big winner of the debate last night that
was Kamala Harris who also get to
Pete Budaj edge we've had sort of a
mixed night and we'll get to the very
greatest of all the candidates that of
course would be Marianne Williamson I
mean she is spectacular
before we do that you're gonna have to
go over to Daley wire.com and subscribe
if you want to see the rest of the show
live if you want all three hours of the
show including our two hours this
afternoon we'll go over to Daley
wire.com right now $9.99 a month gets
you the subscription $99 a year gets you
the annual subscription which comes
along with this the very greatest and
beverage vessels we are on the road
obviously and this signifies right here
this right here signifies the leftist
here's hot or cold tumblr its
invisibility device its cloaking device
has been activated for safety protocols
you can have that too also when you
subscribe you get access early to our
Sunday special this Sunday special is
david barton who is one of the foremost
experts on american historical
memorabilia and America's religious
foundings it's really great you got that
early on Saturday when you become a
subscriber here's a little bit of what
it sounded like we are different by the
nation's I know professors who drive
some crazy to say American
exceptionalism they hate that the
average length of a constitution in the
history of the world is 17 years this
year we're 232 years under the same
Constitution so we are unique we're the
exception not the rule
it's a really interesting Sunday special
he has great stories about the founding
great insight into who the founders were
go check it out right now over at Daily
wire calm and subscribe also helps
protect us against the vicissitudes of
the big tech overlords some of whom some
not all some of whom are interested in
shutting down debate also it's that time
of the of the week when we reward one of
our subscribers by showing them with the
leftist cheers hot or cold tumblr this
is Meredith and she has a leftist years
hot or cold tumblr it is indeed
magnificent indeed it's Meredith Mentos
she appears to have just aced her
schooling in this picture Meredith is
wearing her graduation gown while
flexing one arm and drinking out of the
glorious leftist here's tumblr with the
other her conference is clearly
justified she's also wearing a stole
visit valedictorian so well done
Meredith Congrats on that she writes
couldn't have done it without these
supporters hashtag left his tears tumblr
right back at you Meredith good job and
good luck next year at Liberty
University that is some that is some
good stuff right there alrighty we'll
see you on the other side your this is
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so if the big loser of the
night was last night was Bernie Sanders
and if the person who put himself most
at risk was was Joe Biden and he heated
because blood is now in the water then
the big winner of course was Carmel hair
she was the most rehearse she was the
most on her game now because she was
rehearsed there's also a certain lack of
charm to her candidacy and what Peabody
Judge is really good at is looking
somewhat spontaneous and frankly people
who judge I think has about 20 IQ points
on everybody else in the Democratic
field so that helps but Pamela Harris is
a very smart person she's also a very
well rehearsed person she's the most
politician e of all the politicians as
she does her stick a little bit more I
wonder if it's gonna get a little tired
because people are looking for
authenticity and spontaneity and Kamala
Harris is a shark I mean my goodness if
there's blood in the water she is a
shark and you can tell how her her she
is because even some of the lines that
shouldn't really be rehearsed are
totally worst here's an example so
everybody last night did moderators just
did a horrific job they did a terrible
job with the mics they didn't distribute
time properly Andrew yang ended up with
three minutes of total time in a
two-hour debate so well done moderators
it gave Kamala Harris the opening to be
the adult in the room which is I'm
honestly shocked I mean these people are
so unprofessional I'm shocked that
nobody else in the room did this but
Kamala Harris
she sort of parachuted into the middle
of everybody's screaming at each other
like it's a mad mad mad mad world and
then she went you know guys we all need
to calm down but she doesn't with the
most for a Hearst and canned line ever
and then get two big rounds of applause
because everything is stupid
hey guys you know what America does not
want to witness the food fight they want
to know how we're gonna put food on
their table so I will mode something
else and that is that the crowd was
stacked for Harris from the very outside
I mean I noted this on Twitter it is
obvious that who whoever's in the crowd
makes a huge difference in these debates
Bernie Sanders was not getting any
applause for his cheer lines Kamala
Harris was getting applauded for every
dumb thing she said one of her big
applause lines and she was talking about
when the president has the microphone in
her hand and everyone's like ooh her
because she's a woman I get it I get the
joke Wow oh my and people are cheering
up so is that gonna wear over the course
of a two-year campaign which is what
this is I don't know but she had a good
night last night now
she's unbelievably radical she's
unbelievably radical by this I mean that
the positions she takes are so far
outside the mainstream I don't know how
she walks them back at a general
election so for example she was asked
about decriminalizing illegal
immigration there's this really dumb
debate that is now broken out among
Democrats over whether it's section 1325
of a federal code which makes it a
criminal act to cross the border into
the United States between ports of entry
whether that should be repealed so now
it'd just be a civil fine and you would
just be detained and you wouldn't be
detained you just be released with a
fine if you cross into the United States
Kamala Harris goes even further in case
she says not only when I decriminalize
crossing the border meaning we can't
hold you until you pending an asylum
claim she's saying not only would she do
criminalize it she would also make sure
that she would not deport any one anyone
so in other words if you cross the
border illegally you rush that Rio
Grande you come across the other side
let's say what they cannot arrest you
they can issue up basically a parking
ticket they give you a piece of paper
that says you now owe us $100 okay
skedaddle and then presumably everybody
just sort of rushes into the Arizona
desert and if you make it welcome you're
now an American here is comel Harris
basically making this insane case I say
no absolutely not they should
be deported and I actually this was one
of the very few issues with which I
disagreed with the administration
because the policy was to allow
deportation of people who by Isis own
definition were non criminals
so as Attorney General and the chief law
officer of the state of California I
issued a directive to the sheriffs of my
state that they did not have to comply
with detainers and instead should make
decisions based on the best interest of
Public Safety of their community so they
would not respect ice detainers right
this her case right now is that not only
should localities ignore the federal
government's request for detainers of
people who may or may not be criminals
for deportation outside of the
criminality of crossing the border
illegally she says she would not deport
a single human being who crosses the
border illegally none unless they've
committed some other crime okay well at
that point you may as well not have a
border in seriously you may as well not
have a border you may as well just call
Mexico a part of the United States
except that they get to have their own
governments because that's insane and if
she wants more dead migrants crossing
that Rio Grande border I can't think of
a better way to do that than to say to
them listen you go through a port of
entry and you may have to go through an
asylum process but you crossed between
ports of entry you answer we'll give you
a parking ticket let you go and then you
just get to stay here forever my
goodness if she thinks that is a
mainstream American position who now
come Ohio's also happens to be a tyrant
so she kept suggesting things like on
day one I'm gonna do X and the X was
something that Congress actually has to
do so she would say on day one I'm gonna
repeal Trump's tax cuts yeah how you
gonna do that
how you gonna do that your presidents of
the United States if you're elected
you're not even in the legislature
it takes an active legislature to repeal
a tax cut but according to Kamala Harris
day one she's gonna do all this stuff
she's a dangerous figure a really
dangerous figure also she's a damned
liar and when I say that I mean that she
has now lied multiple times about her
position on private health insurance
everybody's ignoring this because she
was leading a charmed life last night
but the fact is that you'll recall that
she had an actual Q&A on CNN just a few
weeks ago in which she was asked whether
she would abolish private insurance and
she said absolutely all abolish private
insurance I'm
medicare-for-all just like Bernie get
rid of private insurance through 177
million Americans off their health care
plan just do it
and then two days later said no you know
I didn't really mean that I meant that
people should should mostly be able to
be on public insurance but if they want
their private insurance they can either
the public option is what I meant well
last night they asked the question on
stage would you abolish private
insurance and guess what Kamala Harris
did she raised her hand alongside the
only other Democrat on the stage who did
Bernie Sanders here's what that looked
like who here would abolish their
private health insurance in favor of a
government-run plan so the only two
people on stage are Bernie Sanders and
Carla Harris she knows precisely what
she's doing there because nobody else on
the stage is raising their hand she
knows what that question means now she
didn't get a follow up on it of course
because the moderators suck but not
beyond that beyond that she then comes
out okay so she is now flipped her
original position was not abolishing
private insurance then she flipped - I'm
abolishing private insurance then she
flopped back - I'm not abolishing
private insurance then she just flipped
back - yes I'm abolishing private
insurance and then this morning she
flopped back - no I misunderstood the
question I'm not abolishing private
insurance and she's just she's a liar
she's a liar okay I don't know how else
you can put it it's not as though she
didn't know this question was coming
they asked it the previous night it's
not as though she hasn't had time to
think over the issue she made this gaffe
like a month ago here she was this
morning being asked about her purse oh
this oh this morning she was
specifically asked about it and she
backed off of it
senator another defining moment in the
debate was when every candidate was
asked to raise their hand if they would
abolish private insurance in that moment
you raised your hand but afterwards her
campaign says actually that's not your
position so what is your position on
private insurance so the question was
would you be willing to give up your
private insurance that's not how it was
such a plan and that's what you heard
right okay yeah that's certainly what I
heard and in terms of I am supportive of
Medicare for all and under Medicare for
all policy private insurance would
certainly exist
and for supplemental coverage she said
no she said no it turns out that I'd
misunderstood the question
my fault my bad sure sure lady okay but
in essence because of that exchange was
Biden that it's the clips that matter
that exchange with Biden is going to win
her some now as I say if Biden survives
this he's probably the nominee because
it means that he's basically Teflon if
however he starts to sink in the polls
and people get the perception that he's
old that he can be damaged then he's not
and you know who picks up a lot of that
ground not Elizabeth Warren who had a
lackluster night not Bernie Sanders who
had a lackluster night a lot of that
support is gonna go to Kamala Harris so
Kamala Harris just bumped herself back
into the top tier of candidates now the
other candidate who had what I thought
was a pretty good night was people who
to judge Buddha judge really shines on
stage he's quite good at this he's very
articulate
he says insanely radical things but he
does so in the mannerism of moderate II
which is of moderation which is really a
good skill he says now he does have this
one weird tic that he keeps going back
to which is implying that everybody who
doesn't support the agenda that he likes
is not actually religious and it's not
actually a question I don't think that's
gonna play in a general election very
well at all people feel like they're
being attacked for their religion by a
person who not only supports same-sex
marriage I mean he is a a gay man who is
married to another man
but also supports abortion on demand
whole points of birth heroes people who
judge lecturing Americans about their
religion which is a very weird thing to
do in a democratic debate the Republican
Party likes to cloak itself in the
language of religion
now our party doesn't talk about that as
much largely for a very good reason
which was we are committed to the
separation of church and state and we
stand for people of any religion and
people of no religion but we should call
out hypocrisy when we see it and for a
party that associates itself with
Christianity to say that it is okay to
suggest that God would smile on the
division of families at the hands of
federal agents that God would condone
putting children in cages has lost all
claim to ever use religious language
again vice-president okay what the hell
is he talking about who is out there
saying that God would smile on the
seperation of children and parents like
who's doing this again that sort of
language is really
radical now Buddha jej is very
articulate he had a lot of good moments
last night where he seemed like the only
reasonable person on stage sort of
posing himself as he always should have
as the younger alternative to Biden if
he want somebody who's moderate vote
Buddha jej who's younger and
better-looking and more articulate than
old slow Joe
I actually thought too there's a moment
with Buddha judge last night where Eric
swallow who as I say was the designated
torpedo last night where Eric swallow
went after Buddha jej and this is being
read in a couple of different ways I
actually thought the Buddha judge
handled this about as well as a Democrat
could because again you're not allowed
to tell the truth on a Democrat debate
stage so if the actual answer to swells
question is the facts aren't in I'll
respond to them when they're known but
he's not allowed to say that
swallows asking him about a police
shooting that happened in South Bend
that has created a bunch of media
controversy because a police officer
allegedly shot a man who was allegedly
carrying a knife the man was black the
police officer was white the body
cameras weren't operational and Budaj
Edge has basically been sitting there
and taking the heat for it that's the
only thing he can do in the Democratic
Party again it's an unfair attack by
swallow because as everybody knows you
don't know the facts what exactly is he
supposed to do as the mayor but
according to SWA well apparently he
should fire the entire police department
and replaced them with the new Black
Panthers or something swallows a crazy
person here is booty judge responding my
community is in anguish right now
because of an officer-involved shooting
a black man Eric Logan killed by a white
officer it's a mess and we're hurting
and I could walk you through all the
things that we have done as a community
all of the steps that we took from bias
training to de-escalation but it didn't
save the life of Eric Loeb we've taken
so many steps toward police
accountability that you know the FOP
just denounced me for too much
accountability we're obviously not there
yet and I accept responsibility for that
you should fire the chief so under
Indiana law this will be investigated
and there will be accountability for the
officer but here the mayor you should
fire the chief if that's the policy and
someone died okay and then the moderator
jumped in and say boo to judge right but
the fact is that buda judge is giving a
reasonable adult answer well soir well
is not I thought the Buddha judge had
himself a pretty good night now do I
think that that means that he is a tops
your Kent I still think that Buddha
judge is probably the favorite to be VP
I think that a Harris Buddha judge
ticket looks very good for Democrats
it's diverse in every way that is
possible to be diverse and at the same
time as radical in all the ways that it
is possible to be radical those were the
two big winners that last night except
for one big winner I mean the biggest
winner of all and that of course is
Marianne Williamson now I know that we
are all praying here at the Daily wire
for Marianne Williamson to win the
Democratic nomination and the reason we
are all praying for her is number one
according to Marianne Williamson prayers
are like little birds that float into
the sky but come down in your heart as
spaceships I'm really looking forward to
Marianne Williamson debating Donald
Trump on vaccinations or something I
just think that this is this is what
America deserves we've had this coming
and we deserve to get a good and hard
Marianne Williamson was a delight last
night I mean an absolute delight so she
led off with a point about President
Trump she said if you think that plans
are gonna be Trump you are wrong now
here's the thing what she's saying has
like a grain of truth to it but she's so
odd and bizarre and charmingly kooky and
she's like she's like a Diane Keaton
character from a Woody Allen film in
1974 marianne williamson so here is
marianne williamson saying you guys are
up here talking about plans you know it
will beat Trump something here we go go
go for Mary Ann I want to say that while
I agree with I'm with senator Bennet and
others but I agree with almost
everything here I'll tell you one thing
it's really nice of the god of these
plans but if you think we're gonna beat
Donald Trump by just having all these
plans you got another thing coming
because hitam wins I think he had a plan
he won by simply saying make America
great again okay and then she said we
need to talk about deeper things like
make America great again everybody on
stage is looking at each other like
Trump didn't win because he was deep but
what she's actually saying there kind of
has a grain of truth to it which
that make America great again has more
emotional resonance to people than any
of the plans anybody else is talking
about I'm sorry I have to show you more
marianne williamson it is it is required
some Marianne Williamson her best moment
was her closing so people were asked
what you would do on your first day as
president her answer is so glorious it
is just spectacular I have an idea about
Donald Trump Donald Trump is not going
to be beaten just by insider politics
talk he's not going to be beaten just by
somebody who has plans he's going to be
beaten by somebody who has an idea what
this man has done this man has reached
into the psyche of the American people
and his harness fear for political
purposes so mr. president if you're
listening I want you to hear me please
you have harnessed fear for political
purposes and only love can cast that out
so I sir I have a feeling you know what
you're doing I'm going to harness love
for political purposes I will meet you
on that field and sir
love woman is she propositioning the
president she's gonna meet him on the
field of love and then harness him with
love or something is that what are you
supposed to gain from that I don't know
but it was delightful preach it sister
my goodness that is some strong stuff
from Marianne Williamson I support her
I'm donating to our campaign I want her
in every debate forever Republican and
Democrat I don't care that is some solid
stuff she also by the way finished the
debate by suggesting that she was going
to call the prime minister of New
Zealand we have the clip of her of her
talking but yes yes play it
[Music]
who said that her goal is to make New
Zealand the place where it's the best
place in the world for a child to grow
up and I'm the type of girlfriend you
were so on because the United States of
America is going to be the best place in
the world for a child to grow up let me
say girlfriend you are so on
well alrighty well Marianne Williamson
for president man I am on the bandwagon
okay time for a quick thing I like and
then a thing that I hate so things that
I like today I do love delusion delusion
is is truly wonderful and beta O'Rourke
is participating in the grandest
illusion that I have seen in quite a
while so beta just broke his face the
other night I mean he was in the first
night's debate giant fail
blew himself up looks like he stepped on
a landmine circa Tropic Thunder I mean
just horrific showing by beta or up the
other night finished his candidacy off
it was so bad he had to put on a tie
while going on TV you know it's bad for
beta when he doesn't put on his favorite
shirt beta was on with Allison Cammarata
on CNN and she asked him how he would
grade himself on his debate performance
and he said words the words are not true
but they're delightfully delusional
maybe he and marianne williamson can
team up for a third party candidacy i'm
for it here's beta what grade would you
give yourself for last night I'd give
myself an A I wanted to make sure that I
got that point across I described why
I'm doing this who I'm doing it for the
people that heard me and how we're going
to meet these challenges and it felt
like I was able to get that across man
the man has no insight into himself he'd
give himself an a because his whole life
he's been giving himself in a for
underperforming his well he gave himself
an A for not beating Ted Cruz in the
Senate he gave himself an A for serving
in Congress without a shred of actual
achievement he gave himself an A for
spending most of his twenties running
around the country dressed up as a furry
I mean like yeah I'd give myself an a
abroad because is what I've been getting
for my entire life and also like I like
the letter A grade a beta gotta love him
okay time for a quick thing that I hate
so Bill DeBlasio giant groundhog serial
killer mayor of New York he made a
boo-boo he went down to Miami because
that's where the democratic debate was
and he then proceeded to drop a phrase
that was a direct quote from Che Guevara
now because he's a and also a
communist he thinks that this is not a
big deal in Miami where all of the Cuban
expatriates live or people who escaped
Castro's evil regime and hate Che
Guevara
live and it's just amazed it's so good
so Bill de Blasio's on CNN saying I
didn't know that Che Guevara's
said that really so why did you use a
direct quote from Che Guevara it's not
like this is a famous
phrase that people just sort of
generally use it's a direct quote from
Che Guevara
but even Wolf Blitzer who is not the
brightest bulb in the basket is able to
basically demolish Bill de Blasio
national TV over this as you know it's
deeply offensive to a lot of Hispanics
especially those Cuban Americans who are
down in Miami well well if I understand
that now and obviously if I had
understood the phrase is origin better I
would not have used it but it is simply
a case of I literally understood it as a
Spanish language translation of
something I was trying to say these
working people about the fact I thought
they would be victorious in the end and
I apologize I think in life you have to
as a leader be able to save you did
something wrong even if it didn't mean
to apologize and say look I certainly
didn't mean to offend anyone I
understand the sensitivities I've
learned from that mistake just really um
okay so the fact that Bill DeBlasio gets
away with something like that is pretty
somebody's not getting away with it
nobody nobody's going anywhere bill de
blasio he's basically toast
okay so we'll be back here a little bit
later today with two additional hours of
content we have lots of good stuff
coming up for you this afternoon so this
is why you should subscribe there will
be more laughs more tears more forced
political jokes it'll be fantastic go
check us out over at daily we're calm or
we will see you here not next week I'm
actually off next week but the following
week so take care of yourself stay
healthy out there and calm yourselves
it'll all be fine have a wonderful July
4th I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
hey guys overall the Matt Walsh show
today another debate we've got many more
of these to go unfortunately god help us
we'll go over the highlights and or I
guess I should say the lowlights of the
debate including among other things the
Democrats all admitting that they want
to give free health care to illegals
which is something that up until
recently they denied so we'll talk about
that and an especially disgusting
article goes viral online featuring a
woman bragging about all the times that
she's cheated on her boyfriend and
recommending that other people do the
same so we'll discuss that as well and
answer your emails today on the Matt
Walsh show